Before we start answering the question of "What is motion?" or "How do we describe it?",
let's quickly go over why we want to learn about motion at all.
Well, first, understanding motion gives you an incredible predictive power.
Whether you want to know the path that a soccer ball takes as it flies to the goal
or the speed of the rollercoaster as it goes through a loop,
you will need to know about motion.
Second, this is an important tool to have in your physic tool belt.
The math and the physical techniques we used will be used throughout the class.
Finally, and this is the most important reason for me personally, is to solve one of the nature's puzzles.
There're so many facets of nature out there that are just begging
to be understood, and motion is one of them.
Galileo Galilei did a lot to help us learn about motion, but before we jump into his contributions,
let's talked a little bit about Aristotle, whose concept of motion
was widely accepted until Galileo came on the scene.
To get some of these historical contexts, let's go to Florence, Italy,
where we'll talk to Professor Thomas Settle, an expert in the field of Galileo,
about some of this context.